yo what's good it's your boy Eric
Bellinger make sure you check me out on
a bootleg calf podcast it's 8
yes we got a special guest in here my
guy one of the most prolific R B singers
and Writers come on baby just finished
his tour Eric Bellinger Is Here Yeah man
we're here we're here congrats on
another successful tour thank you dog
appreciate you dog always amazing to
finish up relax and chop it up with the
home what's the first thing you do like
when you get off tour like is it like
how's that first day are you relaxing
your kids very first day yes very first
day I came home when I was unpacking the
trailer and unloading all the suitcases
they came home from school Daddy got
that moment off and I didn't do anything
for the rest of the day I make sure I
just dedicated that night to them but
better believe I woke up the next day
back to it back to it multiple
interviews multiple sessions so
yesterday I went crazy and today I woke
up it's the second day off and we
already back at it at the second
interview today you definitely you have
a song you're pushing you got an album
yeah so you got you're you're you're
you're right the door is over but the
workers don't stop that's what I was
saying man that's what you got to do you
know you gotta sign up for both and a
lot of artists don't know that they just
like they just want to drop it and they
go viral but you really really got to go
crazy with the marketing once the song
is out to let the people know it's there
man yeah I was gonna say for you like uh
how do you do the work life balance with
the family and because you're a
hard-working guy you know you're always
in sessions you're always moving around
like what's the key to that
so I think it's like especially you can
start off with like weekends like trying
to be like yo weekends we gonna have a
day where we hang set aside for the kids
yeah set aside for the kids
um wifey yo we're gonna make sure we do
a day night at least every two weeks or
something you know every week is it's
hard yeah you would love that but you
got to be real with yourself and not set
too high of expectations and if you get
that extra day then you you good but to
be able to to Really push and not have
the pressure while still having the
support has been a blessing every two
weeks I like that minimum I need to push
that to my wife look two let's go eat
you know even if you know you got to get
a sitter gotta get the babysitter man
gotta do it because it's important man
just keep falling in love
um your new album uh how many records is
it 14 14 obviously the corday record in
fabulous record is dope I got to
actually pop in on the video shoot for
that you shot at Super Bowl yeah Super
Bowl weekend in AZ yeah where you were I
look at you like
the pivotal moment for me even shooting
a video shooting the Curious video bro
what do you mean like JD told me that
you had booked Fab for the weekend oh
yeah yeah for the club for your club and
I saw a window of being able to be in
the same place at the same time we had a
show in AZ as well around the same time
yeah it was a it was the same weekend
yeah yeah so it was like yo let's make
it happen corday can we get him there
he was down we flew him in town but it
was started because
you and you guys shout out to y'all for
putting my club in the video I love that
I guess we was like yo the club scenes
are definitely from 11 11 in Scottsdale
yes sir maximize yes good times man for
you like um how because when you're in
album mode and you're because you're
obviously we talked about that we did a
radio interview in San Diego but we got
to kind of reflect on how many bodies of
work you have at this point how many is
it now
it's like 38 it's like closing on 40 if
you include like mixtapes and stuff like
on the on the albums on just on iTunes I
have like 28 or something like that but
there's so many that I couldn't put on
iTunes so like Spotify yeah
do you damn when did you first like
really dive into
the full-time artist crime yeah
um when I dropped goat okay 2017 2018.
that doesn't feel like very long ago I
feel like you've been on like no because
I've been dropping I would say like
2010. okay okay 2010 is when I put my
very first mixtape out
um 10 10 10 and I think it just was a
grind of me dropping projects just out
of I create so many that I'm dropping
not knowing that they would eventually
amount to streams that pay monthly
royalty you know I mean it was just like
I'm dropping you know I'm independent
damn I should be signed to a major oh I
should be signed to a major little do I
know that me owning my masters would
give me a bigger piece of the pie at the
end of the day yeah because I can only
assume
when you have 28 projects out it's like
kind of like residual income just
hitting that account every month that's
it that's all it is once since I started
piling up I was like
oh why do we need a label what is that
for again it's it's really if you need
the uh really the label is if you need
The Upfront nut at that time yeah you
know what it is it's like hey so you
don't you don't use your own money you
don't want to invest your own time and
that's fine and also like some artists
like you know I think a major label
system probably better suits some
artists so I can raise your guys you
know yeah yeah yeah guys who kind of
lazier guys you know it just is what
like if you're gonna be independent it's
the work is it's strenuous it's a lot
you got to wear multiple hats for sure
you know you got to be willing to take a
no and you know flip it and be on for
you like uh talk to me about just like
the the day-to-day stuff that you handle
being independent obviously you're with
Empire who's doing distribution who
helps the label services but like what
are you handling yeah as EB Yeah man so
I'm tapping to
the storyline of the album so you got
the writing creative in the studio then
you got the mixing process then it's
time to think of what the artwork's
gonna be the colors the aesthetic now
you got single artwork every single
attached and coinciding with the
previous to remind people that this is
all for one body of work now you got a
photo shoot that is intentional to take
people back to a time so I'm bringing
out the leather I'm leather head right
Toe with the R B Energy now we gotta
talk about music videos and I'm on the
line with the directors I'm planning I'm
picking I'm casting I'm looking for the
for the ladies I'm talking to emails
shout out to emails Diddy always came
through we shot four videos with my guy
and brought nothing but beautiful ladies
to go crazy in the videos with us man
The Styling of the videos now you got
the marketing so you're putting your
fingerprints on everything yeah I'm not
I'm not there's nothing that I don't
know that's happening that's amazing man
do you feel like I just heard Russ say
this recently that he feels like music
videos aren't as effective as they used
to be at this point it's like a branding
thing in terms of in terms of just like
the ROI on streams yeah can you see that
yeah because we spend more on music
videos than you'll get from the music
video stream wise you have to stream
like or it has to have like
certain amount so like a commercial yeah
before you can even get the return on
investment yeah because you think like a
good music video like a good one you're
gonna spend at least five grand exactly
okay I was just talking about that today
a good one okay so you can get a decent
one for like 212.
look if you got a homie with a camera
and you got some [__] aspirations and
you're willing to do it for sure
yeah get that right lighting you know
what's gonna make a difference in the
long run to just do it right the first
time instead of trying to go back and
shoot Another music video and now the
streams are you know what I mean gotta
do it right the first time 100
um talk to me about your
uh you're just I feel like every Chris
Brown album you somehow have your
fingerprints on in some capacity yeah
um how did you guys first link up and
just talk about why he trusts you so
much yeah so uh he's also a great writer
he is he is that's why I you know I
definitely don't take it lightly
um just that you know that trust uh the
first song we did was called Champion it
was for a London artist named chipmunk
Harmony called me in for the session I
wrote The Hook and he just re-cut the
hook and was like yo whoever did that
whoever that was singing I want them to
work on my next album so he brought the
whole team with Harmony and myself and
Courtney and and we all went to the man
straight in with Chris Brown you know
what I mean I was I was actually in
London working
um and had to get a call to come back
the next day literally like I landed had
to go right back I didn't do no work and
we got in with him and wrote all the
songs on on um Fame oh my love uh
Champion ended up going on there say it
with me and did not joined one of his
first White Grammy was Fame
the first album after kind of the whole
shindig that went yeah yeah the graffiti
kind of art yeah so that was like kind
of his comeback that was the one and it
got a Grammy so it's like we was
involved in such a pivotal moment I feel
like uh it was like let's keep doing it
yeah and then you did find China right
yeah Fine China is such a great record
man that's that's my favorite one though
I should say when you write a song like
Fine China are you with him or do you
send it to him and if you send it to him
are you kind of hoping he doesn't want
it so you keep it for yourself nah I'm
with him okay yeah I'm with him uh any
of the songs that are like the big ones
like New Flame and love more it was all
there yeah but when I'm by my myself a
lot of them songs nobody I don't be
playing them for nobody you know for one
it's like I'm gonna keep this and I can
do whatever I want with it and it's
gonna benefit me more low-key to have
ownership of the song as opposed to
um if I go to a session and I'm with
somebody else that's their studio time
they pay for that that's most likely
they beat so I never really be too
connected I'm always like pouring all my
energy into the moment was Usher in the
session for New Flame Usher was not
Usher was not he's on that song yeah
he's on that song
um who else somebody else someone else
is singing song yeah I feel like there's
a rapper no it wasn't Rick Ross
somebody's on that side it might just be
him in Russia it might be
I feel like I'm missing a rapper you're
a [__] no you wouldn't know baby
my guy over there big Yeet fan yeah Have
you listened to Yeet I just seen his
logo he's popping as [__] I just seen it
pop up on the page I don't get it it's
not for me to get the name hey it's so
many things that come out now I'm like
wow it's so many different names of new
people and artists and it's just like I
just respect it because I remember when
it was like who's this Eric Bellinger
guy what up y'all we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our folks at
my bookie look baseball season it is
back in full swing and my bookie your
One-Stop shop for everything you need to
get money off of your favorite baseball
teams your favorite baseball players all
the betting knees they got you man so
many different options including money
lines the Run lines totals Futures all
of it my bookie gives you plenty of ways
to bet on your favorite teams and
players and get some of that money you
can also take advantage of the brand new
my bookie money bag it gives you the
chance to secure a bet on your favorite
team or player at crazy boosted odds
which got to do right now sign up in my
bookie use the promo code bootleg to
secure a first deposit bonus up to a
thousand dollars now how that works is
if you deposit two hundred dollars
you get to play with 300 instantly
that's what we're doing all right all
you got to do is use that promo code
bootleg to claim your bonus ASAP so look
if you're a baseball fan there's so much
excitement when it comes to betting
baseball you know I would say baseball
is one of the funnest and easiest
Sports to gamble on if you really know
what the [__] you're doing uh plus we
got the NBA Playoffs coming so much
happening with the playoffs we got to
play in tournament we got the uh let's
see
I love the series the Cavaliers versus
Nets Knicks because the Nets are not
playing the Cavaliers the Knicks are
wrong New York team Suns versus Clippers
[__] Hammer the Suns
minus 200 to beat the Clippers it's
gonna happen all right so look go to my
bookie right now sign up with that promo
code bootleg and get that first deposit
bonus ladies and gentlemen it's so easy
I promise you my book he's got it
covered for you baseball uh of course
basketball NBA playoffs Futures you go I
mean they got the casino popping they
got Blackjack they got roulette they got
it all
mybookie.ag promo code bootleg cab promo
code bootleg actually go sign up you'll
see it it's right there
and we got to give a big shout out to
the good Folks at Blue chew that's right
ladies and gentlemen it's getting a
little hot outside that's right it's
getting super hot it is getting hot
finally I'm tired of this [__] cold
ass weather you know what that means
it's [__] season baby that's right if
you are you know maybe dealing with a
little erectile dysfunction
it happens to the best of us you don't
have to be an old guy to get Ed you
might just have a we don't even say what
you might have but maybe you're dealing
with stress at work maybe you're dealing
with stress at home and you're not
performing up to par maybe your penis
could be a little bit more harder let's
be honest that's really what we're
talking about here right go to
bluetooth.com right now and use the
promo code bootleg and you can get a
month's supply for free that's right a
month supply for free at bluetooth.com
now a lot of people are asking what is
Bluetooth how does it work does it work
one of course it works two how does it
work it has the same active ingredients
as Viagra and Cialis but it's in a blue
chewable tablet yes it's a chewable all
right and the best part about it you
don't even have to go to the doctor's
office to get it it's all online you
don't have to have any sort of embarrass
embarrassing conversations with people
in regards to you know you're junk now
working the way you want to work or
whatever the [__] all you got to do is
go online to bluetooth.com
they're going to get you situated with
your first month for free as long as you
use that promo code bootleg free month
supply of blue shoe use the promo code
bootleg it gets delivered straight to
your door discrete packaging plus they
got the new mint flavor which is the
same exact active ingredient is Levitra
so many ways you can Bluetooth man I'll
tell you this though it's about to get
hot as [__] outside you're about to hit
that spring break you want to make sure
you're equipped you know what I mean
bluetooth.com promo code bootleg get a
free month on me all you do is pay five
dollars in shipping what's up y'all
bootleg Kev here gotta tell you about
our homies uh who are our new sponsor at
the podcast and it's so dope that we got
to work with them because I've been
using their product for so long I'm
talking about the homies at King Palm
baby that's right shout out to King Palm
y'all don't know all natural
tobacco-free no additive Leaf wraps all
right they're literal Leafs all right
and when I tell you they're the best uh
they're the industry leader when it
comes to the tobacco-free Natural Leaf
wrap situation and my [__] is this they
got these uh amazing wraps that come
with these
flavor infused terpene tips and these
ones right here
the red rains are a movie shout out to
the red rains because the dope thing
about these is they taste like a goddamn
energy drink when you squeeze the tip
all right there's so much you can get
when it comes to King Palm so many dough
products of course their stable product
is that empty Leaf tube with the
pre-installed filter tip no need to lick
or roll it all you do is just pack it
with what you want some of them legal
herbs and get it in all right and check
this out right now you can go to the
website kingpom.com use the promo code
bootleg Kev for 50 off so much we're
talking about rollable wraps hemp cones
and all the essential smoking
accessories you will ever need for the
smoothest smoke easy to use go order
them right now kingpom.com with that
promo code bootleg calf or go to your
local smoke shop even that 7-Eleven
that's on the Block they're gonna have
the King Palm they are the pioneer of
the natural Leaf wrap and they're
getting you hooked up right now at
kingpom.com promo code bootleg Kev half
off all right shout out to King pong the
Watermelons are fire too I'm gonna go
with the watermelon and the energy drink
the red rain gas or you can just go with
just the normal boys
you know what I mean man who would like
to smoke just straight natural organic
Don't Panic it's organic man free of
tobacco and additives go [__] with King
Palm using that promo code bootleg kept
at kingpom.com let's get back to the
interview yeah what do you feel like uh
for because I do feel like there has
been a dope Resurgence in like aren't
beginning respect again in terms of like
you know traditional r b coming back
like you know guys like yourself you got
a girl like Ella Mae yeah we go on and
on and on there's so much dope r b in
the world right now
um but you've been pushing through the
whole wave yeah man and I feel like your
first project comes out in 2010
which I refer to as the dark era yeah
because that's when like
EDM got introduced and it was all of
these r b artists that is when it
happened so there was like this was like
the Lady Gaga and I'm the only one still
waving away yeah and so like you're
still putting out traditional r b I
think around that time yeah August was
starting to come out with his mixtape
yeah August Adrian Marcel had a dope
mixtape yeah
but yeah like for you like you've been
through so many areas of r b like uh
yeah do you recall when it like what was
it like to not be cool to be the r b guy
um
because you think Neo's biggest songs
are the yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know what I mean more on the floor
joints you know it was it was not only
did
the r b not become as popular
but I was also I was also I was also
singing
at a time
out and was married too you know what I
mean so like
that wasn't the cool like everybody
wasn't booed up that wasn't like Bagels
like we were being married and making r
b music yeah I was not the right you
feel me and but I I knew like yo also
shout out to Miguel who's holding that
flag too at that time he was yes and he
was for sure and I wasn't I wasn't
aiming to also married at the time ish
maybe he is with his girl ish yeah we've
been going big time the jump sure this
is the big boy when you really in there
yeah and you in there you walk down that
aisle yeah it is right it's different it
is different for sure the commitment was
like I was dedicated we've ride we've we
vibed it out and she held me up when you
once you got that woman that queen that
make you feel like you got it you good
so that sustained me and my fans really
just let me know like yo thank you for
being the only one that we can listen to
when it comes to positive influence in
relationships when it thinks of just
like r b like I want to love on my girl
as opposed to everything being the
opposite you know so me just giving
people another option
it became the standard and it became the
new wave after people got tired of
disrespecting and being disrespected
yeah there was also like like you're
saying there was the Super toxic r b
[__] where it was like Jesus Christ
it was really crazy some of the [__]
that was a girlfriend's girlfriend oh my
God it was going crazy shout out to Trey
Songz yeah the most toxic r b of all
time this is Theo Girl Gotta give it to
him Jesus Christ it's like where'd the
love go God damn it that [__] was gone
it's gone I was just like yo I'm here
and I don't do it for Applause I do it
for a cause you know what I'm saying I
love that man uh we talked about this a
little bit but um okay you did a whole
album with hitmaker he has had a
friendly Feud we'll call it it's I like
it because I think it kind of you know
lets people talk about producers yeah
yeah you know with Hit Boy they're two
very different guys so different hit
boys obvious see touching in the beat
he's sequencing the drums he's
you put NPC in front of Hit Boy he knows
yeah you know what I mean I look at hit
make it as more like um
like a like a 90s type producer where
like the way Diddy is a producer yeah or
the way like uh Quincy Jones is the
president he knows how to get the people
oh Rick Rubin yeah get the right people
in the room get the right writers in the
room kind of conduct a hit record uh
what are your thoughts on this whole
thing yeah hit boy and hit makeup ah man
I think when you talk about that music
that's it you know what I'm saying like
hitmaker is you know conducting the
session and hit boy is literally
producing and musically engineering the
session
but hitmaker's argument wasn't about the
talent when it comes to musicianship he
was just like
I'm on the radio you know that was
always the argument was so to his
argument he won the argument you know I
mean but to hit boys argument he's not
even tripping on the radio I don't even
think he's trying to be on the radio
he's not and also for the record I mean
this guy's done yeah yeah that song is
still you know and hit make it is only
about your current right now this is
what we talking about but hit boy is
like yo I'm planting seeds you know for
the generations to come to discover my
music not for sure and he's like uh the
the nausea is crazy to me yeah yeah
that's he typed in that's what I'm
saying
yeah the music albums he's going he's
going crazy and and and different styles
you know influencing a generation of
making beats like that can't go
undermined have you ever worked with hit
boy yeah a couple times what was the
difference kind of I guess students
um so with Hit Boy it was a much slower
process of like take our time like let's
listen let's let's see what we got let's
see how we feeling and with hitmaker
he's Speedy Gonzalez in the studio what
we got next one okay you got an idea
going to play it boom okay next one okay
next one and he's a next one next one
next one in three hours you got five
songs he's worrying about it tomorrow
what we doing tomorrow and then a week
later he has 30 songs to place artists
come through the studio hey what you've
been working on he has 30 options to
play you know what I'm saying so it's
like it's a factory that he's
intentionally doing as opposed to hit
boy he selective who he's working with
you know what I mean and you know it's
more of like a like a it's almost like
because I've been in the studio I've
been in the studio where they make us
for a sec but hit boy is very like
intentional and it's yeah if you're
gonna go over to chalice and work with
him like block out the night
exactly exactly we're chilling we're
gonna have a loop on we might fall in
love with something and then he might be
like hold on let me switch the idea
start something over because you know
the foundation is music and you know I
just think they they they they they they
re they stand for different things but
they both represent the same thing a hit
and they're both very good at what they
do yes sir at a high level
um
like when you get with hit make it
because I feel do you feel like
you guys are like his Factory process
I feel like you're you're a kind of a
go-to asset for him in terms of like
when you're laying hooks down for him do
you know that they're just they might
end up somewhere else yeah for sure for
sure because he's shopping them actively
with your hook on it to your artist
immediate he was like yo uh I got Ty
coming by this week I got this beat I
need you on it this one it got your name
all over it boom I come through bless
such a great song by the way that album
is super slept on yeah the mai tai album
was [__] raw that's what made me be
like oh no no I'm going over there we
about to work what's up uh Krishan
what's up yeah hit maker what's up uh
Source you know and when you link up
with them and you can add your own
flavor I think that's when you'll be
able to differentiate yourself and keep
your uniqueness uh I also think Jeremiah
is another one of the yeah great
songwriters of our time who don't get
enough credit in that aspect I agree I
agree I think he's another person that's
not really tripping on like
the fame the bright lights the music
videos like the tours like he's just
like man I love I'm from Chicago I love
making music and all the [__] that I'm
spitting is real and the real [__]
connect with it and that's it and you
know I think that keeps his core and his
solid foundation stable why did you
never decide to sign with a major label
um I always felt like I had more that I
could do on my own you know like I felt
like I still can do this or I haven't
got all this off or I haven't exhausted
my resources or I haven't you know had
the right timing of the right album
um and I don't know it was just never
anyone that saw what I saw in myself was
it because you never got the because I
would say that like
the deal terms got to be right yeah the
bread got to be right if you're smart
like you can go just fine whatever it
gets put in front of you you know what
I'm saying yeah so and and it was like
we already said we always had enough
success to make me feel like we were
good like yeah we're good we're good but
I don't know we live in a new day in age
man I definitely feel like you know with
where I'm at I'm not at the same place
when I was trying to to break myself to
gain my own fan base you know now that I
have a fan base now let's Market on a
heavy scan on a heavy you know scale but
before then it's like man you got to
build it you know and I was I was happy
with just building the building it for
the sake of Leverage uh you and A.D did
a whole album together in 2008 in 19 18.
yeah yeah yeah yeah like 18. it was
definitely like pandemic times it was
before the pandemic it had to be yeah
yeah I met your guys's release party it
was it was before it was the last one
before the pandemic it was called Nine
and I remember coming back from Mexico
and then we went to the session and I
had all these different memorabilia from
Mexico I was wearing the Poncho
they hit you with that when you're in
line waiting to get over the Border
there's all those people just trying to
selling everything so I went to the
studio still informed talking Spanish
playing with him he was like man I'm
calling you Pancho belly I'm calling you
Pancho belly and then we started like
joking around and bro we did like nine
songs in two days and was like it was a
surprise project
what's it like to see him kind of evolve
into a media personality and do his
podcast thing no it's it's the evolution
of nine I feel like when we were
dropping that we were making videos and
being Community characters and yeah but
now to see him with Community it's like
dog that's who he was he's a character
you know so now for him to be able to be
himself make everybody laugh even in his
music I got the juice when you hear that
right you want to laugh you know it's a
good guy so happy for him who's on your
Mount Rushmore of r b music r b music
let's say let's let's say from 1992 to
now
all right you gotta go with
man that's a tough one because I want to
go laugh a little bit but you can't you
can't really avoid people like
Cisco back in the day love Cisco
Cisco big inspiration for you because
you've done the uh the hair things yeah
and complete was my [__] Drew Hill's my
favorite
out of all the [__] it's my song
unless I sing I love that out of all of
the [__] 90s r b groups Drew Hill's
my personal favorite nice enter the Drew
is my [__] okay you you tapped in the
red joint
yes and then you gotta you gotta go with
Usher after that
um two more
man Cisco Usher who else I gotta also
throw
I'm throwing love Joe joking
she's blow and
I don't want to just be biased and put
myself in there you know what I mean
like I can't do that yeah don't do that
I'm trying to put like somebody who I
feel like
you know it's different for me to have
the artist but I want to also include
somebody that writes their music too you
know what I mean and I gotta say it
chaos of course
say what you want we're talking about r
b right now we're talking about art only
I've been talking about art from the
start I love R Kelly's music
and his talents
the boy is a bad one when it comes to
the studio and his songs and the and the
and the concepts and The Melodies and
the endless amount of hits for himself
and others yeah I don't think a lot of
people talk enough about like he wrote
for so many other artists yeah Celine
Dion Michael Jackson Aaliyah like B2K
like it could go on so you got to give
him his love when it comes to the music
what's your favorite R Kelly album
tp2 Ah tp2.com that's the one
man I feel like was that tp2.com and
then it was a chocolate factory after
that oh Chocolate Factory was a Vibe but
do you know where I gotta go after that
I love something special Both Worlds
with Jay-Z really yo that album is crazy
it is it is a good album I feel like
because of the drama that surrounded
that album like people don't really be
like [__] tapping in with it like
that but there was some [__] on there oh
my God that [__] was a five I love uh
the self-titled album that you remind me
and yeah yeah obviously the white one no
no it was black it was it was the white
one's 12 Play okay the white one okay
okay and then the best and then white
shirt then R was great oh yeah I was
good it was a double disc it had a it
had uh the rest of the Isley Brothers on
there half on a baby contagious no the
record what was the record with the
Isley Brothers in the music video That's
not contagious no he's [__] and he's
[__] the dude's girl behind his back
yeah ain't that it y'all continue
you know what I'm talking about
it's gonna bother me now he's [__]
Ron eisley's girl in the video he's like
Frank shut up
can't you see two men that one no no
I'll tell you right now no that's still
yours you're contagious here it is it is
not half oh when a woman's fat wait a
woman is it When a Woman's Fed Up the
video yeah video is contagious
I'm telling you
is it is it contagious it's contagious
When a Woman's Fed Up
she started it but the story continues
yeah I don't know I'm just thinking of
that music video
which was incredible
Ron Eisley
playing a mafioso boss yes
[__] great that's that's when I came
up you know so you know I know my man is
receiving flag but hey we gotta stop the
interview to our our great sponsors at
hardean Las Vegas you see him the SE
amazing box
things in what kind of things
premium things that you can buy at
Jardin Las Vegas yeah if you're in Vegas
stop off at hardine tell them I sent you
they'll take care of you all right
number one dispensary I've ever been
into the nicest dispensary in the world
they got their own [__] scent they
got the biggest craziest selection of
Premium cannabis you will ever see in
your life you walk in and you feel like
they just treat you like family as soon
as you walk in all right so look this is
what you're gonna do you're gonna go to
hardinglasvegas.com check them out go
follow them online Harding underscore
Las Vegas and when you're in Las Vegas
this is your first stop
you don't go to the [__] Casino you
don't go to the you go to [__]
hardeen get situated say bootleg have
sent me I heard about him on the bullet
cat podcast they're gonna take care of
you they'll throw a little a little
extra on it on the extra you know what I
mean go follow them Harding underscore
Las Vegas and of course you can also
follow them right now by going to their
website check out what they got going on
man they got the gear for sale they just
dropped their own pair of Filas Hardy in
Las vegas.com gotta give a shout out to
our oh geez my dogs that Odd Socks baby
they've been [__] with us from day
one
um and they've been dropping so many
crazy dope new like socks you know first
of all can we talk about Beavis and
Butthead they just dropped the Beavis
and Butthead socks and draws let's take
a check just a nice little peek at the
Beavis and Butthead bro
come on man
they also just dropped Coca-Cola we got
Scarface we got Reese's we got the big
[__] Lebowski so many dope socks the
most comfortable socks in the world the
most comfortable underwear in the world
and check this out right now you can get
20 off that's 20 off at checkout at
oddsoxofficial.com using the promo code
bootleg so go right now
oddsoxofficial.com my first uh
suggestion would be get you a pair or a
pack of the Odd Socks Basics the black
and the whites those are my go-to's and
then you gotta [__] with some of these
Big Lebowski socks and they just got
Coca-Cola
they got the Scarface boys like what are
we talking about man what are you
waiting on they are the most comfortable
socks in the world
um so if you're not wearing Odd Socks
you're just cheating yourself you know
what I mean you're really cheating
yourself
they got [__] South Park
come on bro what are we talking about
go to oddsocksofficial.com right now use
the promo code bootleg save 20 off at
checkout on the most comfortable socks
in the world or don't and keep torturing
yourself with those shitty socks you're
wearing right now
be a damn shame anyway let's get back to
the interview what do you feel like your
like ideal output is on a yearly basis
for for dropping music in an album of
years or two albums a year is it I say
two is good yeah you know um I've done
up to four and five
um at a time but it's just so much that
people miss it you know they're too busy
people are too busy to tap in with you
that much and that's the reality
um is your biggest song go
go and Drive by yep
which I don't wanna which which is uh
the record that we were talking about
this in SD you were saying that you had
a record that just kind of out of
nowhere just started streaming because
of tick tock or something
oh that was um because you were like you
were like there was one that was like
like you guys chose to be a single
but drive-by went crazy yep drive by we
yeah we went with goat and you know put
all the energy and all the funds and all
the ideas
yeah to your biggest phones they are but
damn what if we had to put in another
you never know maybe we needed the two
the r b was able to carry itself just
from it being a great song and the other
one needed a little bit of push because
it was a rhythmic song so
um you would uh mentioned to me that you
have sold some of your catalog yeah
because everybody right now is selling
catalogs yeah everybody
um what did you decide to sell and yeah
and what did you say some of the so all
the writing that I've written for Chris
Brown and Usher none of that has been
sold that's all in the can
um just chilling but I've re I've
released so many albums like some of my
older stuff I was like all right cool
let's experiment because we're hearing
all this stuff and it sounds crazy it
doesn't sound real right but let's give
it a shot what am I willing to gamble
with to see if that really happens and I
still got a new I'm still making new
catalog so we cashed out some of the old
stuff yeah seven figures yeah bought
cribs like it bought me my lifestyle you
know like the music so to me it's like I
made music that has
got me able to provide for my family for
real you know that's amazing man
um well listen to what is the amount no
album comes out yeah album's out albums
out yeah uh 1-800 hit easy line two uh
video just dropped curious chord A Fab
and that's that's it man we finished the
tour so now it's really just about
pushing the music uh promoting and you
know going from there any placements
coming up yeah I got some got some heat
coming with Big Sean oh yeah nice single
singles single with Big Sean coming yeah
yeah I don't know if it's the first one
but it's definitely one of them ones
that when you put on you just you feel
good so you know just happy you're on
the hook or is Christmas with my Aries
brother Chris Brown No no no it's all
it's all him oh oh you broke him I'm
just we've just vibed in co-host you
know what I mean I like it I got to be
in the vibe and it was just Aries on
Aries what was it was the session like
with Sean oh man also somebody's in love
yeah exactly someone who's in love I
don't know Vibes great guy first time I
really was able to be in the studio with
him and he was warm he was welcoming he
was open to new ideas and I think that's
what makes people great when they they
know they're good enough to not have to
be the only one coming up with the ideas
you know so once we were able to
piggyback and I got to see which ones he
liked like I did a couple to see like
okay which one is he gravitate towards
the most you know I got to really tap in
and my boy childish major
um we got in and man just cooked up
something real special uh thank you for
coming back because the last time you
try to come on the podcast you came with
hit maker and the elk boys were in the
studio
and they've tried to prank you guys
and things went it went less to say the
least things went left uh Burke did not
appreciate it I feel like you were kind
of like because I let Neiman know that
it was happening yeah he knew and we
didn't know and I was like wait what
happened dude came in
what was we was doing an interview and
the dude came in with a sandblaster yeah
yeah he came in like he was a chair it's
on YouTube it's got me millions of views
on YouTube but your guys's faces are
blurred I gotta see I thought she was
joking no that [__] is online and it's
it went viral I gotta see it so in the
comments everyone's guessing who you
guys are I gotta see that because you
guys faces were blurred yeah please send
me that link shout out to Berg shout out
to hit making yes sir go get the album I
appreciate you man thank you looking
forward to the rest of the year that
what you got in store for us bro oh yeah
man yes sir wait let's go fire